well Harry and Megan joined the rest of
the royal family today presenting a
united front for the procession of the
lake Queen's coffin princess William and
Harry walked side by side behind the
coffin is it left buggy in Paris the
family entered Westminster Hall together
Oprah Winfrey has suggested that the
late Queen's death provides an
opportunity for peacemaking
is she right or is this just a temporary
truce to get through a week that should
all be about of course Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II well of course the big
spanner in the works is looming for the
royal family something I know personally
they're very very concerned about is
Harry's apparently explosive tell-all
Memoir which has been written and is
ready to roll off the presses joining me
now to discuss this sun columnist Tony
Parsons taught to be contributor Esther
crack Laura Megan supporter Paula Roan
Adrian and best-selling author Douglas
Murray is in New York let me start with
you Douglas welcome to the show
um I wrote a comment for New York Post
that really hit a nerve this week about
Harry should pulp this book that now
we've had this dramatic event we've lost
the queen his father is now King and he
made a statement saying it's time to
honor my father King Charles III how is
that compatible with a tell-all book
which will be presumably as most of his
art brawlings have been about his father
very critical of the king
uh yes I I think they're not at all
compatible and I think this must in some
ways be a very lonely time for sorry uh
by all accounts on the day of uh the
lake Queen's death he was having to
arrange his own travel arrangements and
was being reminded the fact that had he
been part of the family still he'd have
been uh you know looked after by them
but he had to sort of go his own way
because he said go his own way uh now
he's seeing some of the costs of that
one of the costs of it I'm sure is a
certain coldness of the family uh how
could you not
um God what you say uh when a family
member has said so many things about a
family ending to say more
um how could he expect he or what expect
to be treated entirely warmly
and they've already said so many untrue
things about the royal family so many
hurtful things and a promising more to
come of course he should pull the Memoir
it's a decent thing to do made plenty of
money from other deals from Netflix from
Spotify and others doesn't to release
the Memoir now I I completely concur
with that but Paula you think he should
be able to publish the book of course he
should of course why he should have the
opportunity to have his set he hasn't
stopped yapping for two years literally
he and his wife barely a week goes by
without them sticking my knife into the
royal family in the monarchy so what do
you mean he's got to have his say he
doesn't stop having his say and we
should say we could say that about the
Press too couldn't we we could say that
about the millions of stories that have
been
um reported in the Press about Twitter
going wild we know that reports have
been done haven't it two members of the
royal family constantly publicly
attacking the royal family and the
monarchy of course the media are going
to respond people said to me when are
you going to stop criticizing Meghan
Markle and Prince Harry when they stop
attacking the royal families just even
in the tone it's very aggressive they're
attacking the royal family they are is
that the case is it the case that they
are telling their truth that they are
finally
they're finally getting an opportunity
there is no such thing as someone's
individual truth when Meghan Markle
talks about my truth it doesn't exist
there is the truth which are facts and
there's everything else and the problem
is you don't have your own version the
problem with with problem with that
argument is is that is exactly why they
needed to have this book because you
will deny you will deny their truth and
you can't continue to do that why should
they be allowed to tell blatant lies
about the royal family well because they
don't believe they are telling let me
give you an example
Meghan Markle told Oprah Winfrey that
their son Archie was not going to be a
prince because of his skin color that's
what she inferred in the answer right so
you're very careful there people as you
may know you're very careful there
because that is what she inferred what
she said which is how you started this
conversation and this is why we need to
be careful because this is such an
emotive topic during this of course
exceptionally sad period of time where
we know that they are a grieving family
and we know that they have done their
absence
I'm not talking about now I'm talking
about when this book lands Tony I think
it's it's going to be like an unexploded
bomb when this thing goes off it's going
to be something which has been ticking
away ticking away I know the palace are
incredibly concerned much more so now
Charles is king because they also fear
Harry might have a go at Camilla who's
known the queen consort of this country
yeah try and settle scores going back to
his parents marriage uh breaking up I do
think there's the law of diminishing
returns I don't think anything will ever
have the impact of that Oprah in
interview I don't think anything
book from Harry because you know it was
so unchallenged you know she Oprah
looked like the worst journalist in the
world everything that was put out there
that was put out there was uncompletely
unchallenged and um and and I think
people were shocked and hurt in this
country because I I went I was among the
crowds at Windsor the day they got
married and there was a genuine real
love and there was no racism and
whatsoever towards Meghan Markle you
know and the idea that from the press in
this country
I know what I wrote for example you
don't know what this country is embraced
embraced the whole thing you don't know
what existed for her and what she didn't
know that Harry is saying because I
noticed that we're focusing on Megan
as well you are concerned about with
this book is the truth
about the truth which is often
completely untrue here's my problem with
it if all they did was tell the truth
that's one thing but 17 different
statements for me open interview alone
were proven to be untrue we still don't
know who this supposed Royal was who
raised concerned about their child's
skin colors I do wish that they actually
said who it was because I thought it was
very mature for them I don't have a
problem with Harry coming up with the
book actually he's not quite an extreme
life no 10 years in the Army you know I
don't have a problem with that but I
think I like I suspect with with good
reason that it's not going to be
tasteful that it could be an attack it
surely he understands now the fictional
truth behind Megan's degree
let me ask Dennis Murray um Douglas
there's a kind of perception here that
they're doing all this because it plays
really well for them in America but the
New York Post cleared its front page for
a very mocking image of of Meghan Markle
originally looking like a a toddler and
a tiara throwing tantrum after tantrum
what is the mood you think amongst the
majority of Americans about what they've
been doing
well there's a deep skepticism about it
um some support uh but also I think just
a lot of embarrassmented a sort of
embarrassment about the fact that Markle
joined the royal family there was as as
several people he said incredible
Goodwill towards her and towards EU I
never saw anything in the British press
that was even remotical of Megan herself
on the day itself of the wedding to been
a happier day the sight of Prince
Charles walk is his new daughter-in-law
up the aisle
um escorting her mother in Saint
George's Chapel it was such a sign as it
was the the photographs of the queen
king her first great grandchild of of
Megan and Harry this was healing things
and there was so much good will around
the world and I'm afraid that Megan and
Harry have through their own shins just
thrown that good will away on both sides
of the event and the trouble started
actually the trouble started when the
whole Fury over her father blew up and
her decision to then completely disown
him and from that moment on you can see
the trajectory of the criticism in the
media building and building because they
then embarked on this huge victimhood
tour where they kept being frankly
hypocritical about things like you know
preaching about carbon footprinting
catching private jets all the time and
so on but also constantly whining
playing the victim the complete
antithesis of what the queen for example
uh stood for uh Douglas thank you for
joining me as always spot on thank you
to my panel